[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez siffler la fin de la
récréation et vous nous avez confié la
seule mission qui va y être à la hauteur
du dérèglement climatique et du chaos
social auquel nous devons faire face
quand ta planète brûle avec les
méga-feux quand elle coule sous les
inondations
vous nous demandez de résister pour que
la france que nous chérissons tant se
saisissent des véritables combats pour
que notre france des villages aux
banlieues des petites villes aux grandes
villes ne sombre pas moralement
vous pouvez compter sur nous nous ne
laisserons pas faire ce naufrage nous
serons là pour défendre une planète
vivante où il fait bon vivre en harmonie
quelles que soient nos origines aux
milieux sociaux nos aspirations parce
qu'ensemble nous allons construire cette
société apaisée que nous appelons toutes
et tous de nos voeux
sandrine herry delphine merci
[Applaudissements]